consider the numbers 1 3 7 and negative
15 2 which of the numbers to which of 2
which sets of numbers listed below does
each of these numbers belong and they
give us a bunch of different sets of
numbers and we could just review these
the natural numbers and you'll see this
used in different contexts some in
different places but for the sakes for
the sake of this video we're assuming
it's the counting numbers and it does
not equal 0 so this is the natural
numbers are 1 2 3 4 so on and so forth
we'll assume that the whole numbers are
essentially the natural numbers plus 0
so the whole numbers are 0 1 2 3 4 so on
and so forth the integers we'll assume
it's the whole numbers plus the opposite
of the natural numbers or the negative
version of the natural numbers so we
would go from knit very negative values
to maybe negative 4 negative 3 negative
2 negative 1 0 1 2 3 4 so on and so
forth rational numbers these are numbers
that can be expressed as the ratio of
two integers so a rational number can be
expressed as M over N where both m and n
are integers and of course n cannot be
in it cannot be n it cannot be 0 because
anything divided by 0 is not defined M
could be 0 and in fact a 0 is a rational
number because zero can be represented
as 0 over 1 or really 0 over 2 or 0 over
3 I think you get the idea or a 0 over
negative 5 537 these are all
representations of 0 and you have an
integer in the numerator integer in the
denominator so 0 is definitely a
rational number you just can't have n
you can't have the denominator be 0
irrational numbers are numbers that
cannot be expressed in this way and so
common versions of irrational numbers
are numbers that you will never see
digits that repeat on go on and on
forever or have series of sequences of
numbers that keep repeating keep
repeating on and on and on and examples
of rational irrational numbers are
square root of 2 or pi and you might
the circumference the diameter of a
circle or you might learn about the
irrational number E which is two point
seven one and it keeps going it doesn't
repeat and then real numbers are really
all of these all of these combined if
you combine the irrational numbers and
the rational numbers the irrational and
the rational numbers then you are
talking about the real numbers every
real number is either rational or
irrational
so let's classify what we have up here
one-third one-third over here let me do
that in a different color so one-third
one-third is it a natural number well no
it's not it's not just a natural
counting number is it a whole number no
it's not a whole numbers and it's in
fact a fraction is it an integer no once
again it is not an integer is it a
rational number well sure it is it can
reread it as one over three both one and
three are integers so one-third
one-third is rational it is irrational
and if something is rational it cannot
be irrational there's nothing that's
both rational and irrational this
literally means not rational and it is
also a real number and it is also a real
number pretty much all of these are
going to be real numbers now let's try 7
out let's try 7 so the number 7 it is a
natural number it is just a regular
counting number it is a whole number it
is a whole number because that includes
there not any natural number is also
going to be a whole number and anything
that is a natural number and that's also
going to be a whole number is also going
to be an integer so this is also an
integer an integer and anything that is
a natural number a whole number or
integer is also going to be a rational
number is also going to be rational and
to see that you can write 7 as 7 over 1
in fact you can write any any integer as
that number over 1 which makes it which
hopefully makes it obvious that that is
also a rational number and if it's
rational you can't be irrational that
literally means not rational and then of
course you're going to be real it's
going to be a real number and you're
going to appreciate later on in your
mathematical careers why we even go
through the trouble of saying it's a
real number because as far as it seems
right
this kind of includes all numbers what
you're going to see in the future is
we're gonna start defining numbers that
don't fall into this category and
they're a little bit philosophically
interesting as well but anyway back to
the problem we have negative 15 negative
15 negative 15 is not a natural number
it's a negative number so it's not a
natural number natural numbers only the
positive the positive integers we could
say whole number it's not a whole number
because that's just the natural numbers
and zeros it is an integer it is an
integer it is the opposite of positive
15 it is an integer so it is an integer
it is rational it can be represented as
15 over 1 so it is rational and because
it is rational it cannot be irrational
and of course it is also real and we are
done